there is apprehension in two cities this
weekend on the one-year anniversary of a
white nationalist rally that left
one person dead the unite the right two
rally is scheduled for tomorrow in
washington dc's lafayette park
organizers predict as many as 400 people
could attend
with counter protesters expected
meanwhile 120 miles to the southwest a
state of emergency has been declared in
charlottesville virginia
where last year's violence occurred cbs
news justice and homeland security
correspondent jeff piguets
reports
about 700 virginia state troopers are
part of the heightened security in
charlottesville
part of the city has been locked down
cutting off all vehicular traffic
and forcing pedestrians through two
checkpoints all until monday morning
nothing would excite us any better than
it's this to be not eventful
and folks to go home and it'd be a
peaceful weekend for all
one year ago white nationalists angered
by a plan to remove a confederate statue
marched through the university of
virginia campus bearing torches while
chanting racist
and anti-semitic slogans the next day
thousands of white nationalists made
their way through charlottesville
streets
only to be met by counter protesters
violence in chaos world for hours
heather heyer was killed when a car
plowed into a crowd of counter
protesters
james alex fields was indicted in
heyer's death and faces dozens of hate
crime charges
now white nationalists have planned a
rally for sunday in washington d.c
at least five counter protest groups
were also granted permits
washington d.c mayor muriel bowser the
only
right message and the message that i
hope that we will carry jointly as
washingtonians
is love inclusion and diversity
guns will be prohibited from the
demonstrations owned in washington but
they are
allowed within downtown charlottesville
uva student
eric patton sharp so what is your main
concern heading into this weekend
main concern is making sure that there
is
total safety for civilians here in
charlottesville
and that the police presence actually
does their job and protects the students
and
community members officials won't say
whether the increased police presence
here is just
as a precaution or in response to a
specific threat
for cbs this morning saturday jeff
begays charlottesville virginia